[Music]
Zig a high performance system
programming language often labeled as a
Next Generation alternative to C it was
created by Andrew Kelly in 2016 and has
quickly evolved into one of the most
desired new languages in the world like
C it's minimal extremely fast and allows
for low-level memory control but instead
of managing memory directly in the
language with functions like Malik and
free the zig standard Library ships
allocators to provide a consistent
interface for memory management Zig is
not a memory safe language like rust or
go but it doesn't have any hidden memory
allocations making the code far more
explicit and portable because allocators
can be easily swapped out in the code to
Target different architectures like x86
arm webassembly and bare metal in
addition Zig has no hidden control flow
if it looks like a function and quacks
like a function it's a function there's
no operator overloading and it doesn't
even have exceptions if a function can
fail it needs to return an explicit
error value the language also has a
unique comp time keyword that makes it
trivial to run Kodak compile time
instead of runtime no preprocessor or
macros are necessary and finally Zig can
integrate well into a c or C plus plus
code base and supports cross compilation
out of the box with llvm although
divorce paperwork has been filed to get
started install Zig then create a new
project with the zignet exe command in
the main file first to import the
standard library then Define a main
function notice how the function returns
a type of void with an exclamation point
that exclamation point means that the
function might return an error declare a
mutable variable with the VAR keyword
followed by a type like you wait to
represent a single byte then assign and
modify its value later or use cons to
Define an immutable variable that cannot
be changed we can also bundle multiple
variables together into a struct then
access them on that namespace with DOT
notation now things start to get more
interesting when memory management comes
into play when initializing an array of
integers we can allocate it to a slice
of memory in the Heap using the built-in
page allocator from the standard Library
what's so cool about this is that we
could swap it out with other allocators
to use different memory management
strategies now when we're done with this
memory we need to set it free otherwise
we could have a memory leak the defer
keyword allows us to put that code right
right next to the allocation itself and
will automatically de-initialize the
list when it goes out of scope now as we
operate on the list the try keyword
provides explicit error handling if this
line fails it will automatically catch
and return the error you can't just
ignore it and that will make your code
more reliable and speaking of
reliability Zig has a built-in testing
framework use the test keyword to
evaluate code outside of the main
program then use the zig test command to
run it and finally build an executable
with the zig build command and choose a
build mode to optimize for Speed size or
safety this has been the zig programming
language in 100 seconds hit the like
button if you want to see more short
videos like this thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one
[Music]